i don't care what little nasa does
because little 9x
got famous because of a joke right the
song
old town which is fine the whole thing's
a troll to me none of it's real
we don't l it's an nft it none of it it
is what it is
by the way our nft should be selling the
target is 80 million dollars and it is
not what do we got two grand
let me check on it you people have no
respect this is our way out of this
business
it's not a joke it's real this nft was
our way
out him and his wife this was their
wedding present
i gotta sign in one second him and his
wife i was gonna buy them a house with
this money and you [ __ ] didn't do it
we thought joe rogan was gonna buy it
for like 500 000
but that guy doesn't have any [ __ ]
money i think we have three bids on it
it's at 1800.
oh oh someone just went up on it so what
do we got now
on it uh to ethereum so we've got 3 300
yeah you guys better i thought we're
getting 80 grand
don't you want to own this
do you not want to own this how are him
and his wife gonna have a wedding
and buy a house that they can live in me
and him are looking at houses now and he
tells me i don't need space
and then i should live with uh in a
house
him and his wife have the house i should
live in that house
he told me that i don't need space we're
driving around and he goes yeah you
don't need that much space
we know you don't need a lot of space
because i don't have uh because i don't
have a family like
because him and his wife have been
together for nine years he just has no
respect for anyone who's not like a
long-term committed relationship
uh with someone else who escaped a cult
and the reality is
uh yeah i do like a little space i have
friends i have people i like
uh opulent and grand surroundings and he
goes you don't need any space
and then he gets mad at me because i i
suggested i had the temerity to suggest
that my house be bigger than his
that's all how many square foot is your
home
uh 2200 and i said i wanted the yard to
be bigger
and i said and then i played my identity
card i said i don't know if the
neighbors like gay people
so like if i'm hanging out with a dude i
don't want to be like
you know sandwiched in between people
that are like hey
um you know or if i say the word [ __ ] or
we're doing a patreon and i say the word
con
i don't think children should have to
hear that language so i want to be
you know i want to have a little space
and live like a person that's done well
and he he's got a [ __ ] problem with
it and tell me like i should be living
in a place like him and his wife that's
not true
but he they're very cookie-cutter people
they have dogs they're
they're like cookie-cutter people so
like they get into these little
cookie-cutter developments
like a dan connie or anybody like that
you should all live in those places
i should have a long winding road with
trees on either end
and so that people know that when they
get to me they're going to meet a genius
that's what it should be i shouldn't
have to make small
talk with the neighbors but you
hate that and i know you and your wife
sit around and go he lives in that big
house
all by himself he doesn't need that
space
he should live in a small community like
we do no you've said
you've said you don't need the space i
don't need the space
i want it i like space
i'm sorry about that i apologize i
apologize
i'm just saying you came at me a little
bit no
we need the space with the yard a
hundred percent but we don't need nine
bedrooms
we don't need nine bedrooms we don't
need nine we don't need nine how many do
we have nine in this house
seven we don't need seven we don't need
seven
how many do you have three well i'll
move in there
tell your wife go big tim you're right
he doesn't need the space he'll be here
tomorrow he's moving in
i mean these two are out of their mind i
think i'm gonna live with them uh in
like some
little community no no no no i'm trying
to live
and it's not even about money it's about
it's about
grandeur do you understand
it's about grandeur it's not about money
i the cookie cutter suburban i've left
the suburbs to live in cities my entire
life
so if i'm out in texas i want to be in
the woods i want to be somewhere cool
that feels different i don't want to be
in a cookie-cutter suburban
thing that's all i mean that's my my
only thing is that i know that like
it's it's lovely and i'm happy for both
of you
but i want to be in in in a more of an
interesting and mysterious
part of the world and you don't respect
that
because you wish that i would like live
on your block
you know and like like some crazy